قال البيت الابيض ان مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جيك سوليفان ناقش في لقاء مع
رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري الشيخ
محمد بن عبد الرحمن ال ثاني جهود اطلاق
سراح جميع الرهائن المتبقين الذين تحتجزهم
حماس بما في ذلك المواطنين الامريكيين
وكان سوليفان قد قال خلال منتدى دافوس ان
على اسرائيل احترام القوانين الدوليه خلال
عملياتها العسكريه على غزه واضاف ان رؤيه
واشنطن لليوم التالي للحرب في غزه تشمل
التطبيع الاقليمي وضمان امن اسرائيل
واقامه دوله
للفلسطينيين مسؤوليه اسرائيل ان تقوم
بالحمله العسكريه بطريقه تحترم القوانين
الدوليه والواجبات الاخلاقيه التي تميز
بين الارهابيين والمدنيين الابرياء كل
الارواح المدنيه اسرائيليه او فلسطينيه او
غيرها تستحق الحمايه الولايات المتحده
ستواصل العمل مع بقيه الدول من اجل
الافراج عن الاسرى وضمان وصول الفلسطينيين
للمياه والغذاء والادويه والامان الذي
يحتاجونه
ويستحقون